welcome back to las vegas now in today's  legal minute eric palacios from eric  palacios and associates the sponsors of  this next segment tells us what are the  penalties for a hit-and-run accident  take a look  i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal  minute this week's question is what are  the penalties for a hit and run accident  this depends on property damage and  injury to others so first if the  property damage is 750 or less and no  one is injured you can face up to six  months in jail in a two thousand dollar  fine number two if someone is wounded or  if the property damage is over seven  hundred and fifty dollars then you're  facing a felony this can put you two to  twenty years in prison and you can have  a fine of two to five thousand dollars  it's important if you suffer an accident  stay put call the police don't hit and  run we'll see you next week on the legal  minute  for more information give eric palacios  and associates a call that number is  702-444-7777  [Music]